Oh,
welcome with the way now the uh,
meeting a goober top,
they're living at series is aimed at getting interesting folks from outside to
speak on interesting topics involving leadership and reaching out to the
community.
My name is me.
I'm the jolly good fellow Google and I'm honored today to introduce a friend,
a better jolly good fellow,
a jolly good fellow for this year.
Connie is the CEO of Zappos and the author of this book,
Delivering Happiness
in 1999 at the age of 24 even younger than me right now.
Cody,
you soul Vegas,
change the company.
He cofounded dual Microsoft for $265 billion.
Do you think joints oppose as an advisor and investor and eventually be,
can see,
oh,
where he helped salvos grow from almost no sales to over $1 billion in annual
sales.
Wow.
See Melt heinously making Fortune magazine's list of best companies to look for
in November.
South horse wants a quiet by amazon.com in the deal value at one point $2
billion.
Tony is a huge inspiration for me.
One of my goals in life is to create happiness in the workplace by doing it from
bottom up.
Buck,
while Tony does it from top down.
S C o n he does is systematically and he does it in a way that is very
profitable for his company.
He's an example.
He's deeply inspiring for me and I hope that you will become a model or odyssey
or see the world and with debt.
Please welcome.
Do you see
[inaudible]
so everyone can hear me.
Okay.
Uh,
want to take a quick survey first.
How many of you have actually purchased from Zappos did before?
Oh Wow.
I didn't know.
So normally when I do this survey,
the ratio is about two to one women to men.
And a lot of guys that I asked say they themselves personally haven't,
but there are some youth,
another or a wife has in.
So I was actually giving a tour of our headquarters in Las Vegas and we actually
give tours to the public.
So next time any of you are in Las Vegas,
uh,
we'll pick you up in his Zappos shuttle from the airport,
give you a tour.
And then drop you off at your hotel afterwards.
It's a lot of fun.
And uh,
I'll give the information later on on how to get it to her.
But anyways,
I was giving a tour to an executive from one of the major record labels and I
asked him the exact same question and he said,
no,
he personally hasn't shopped from Zappos,
but he suspects his wife has because these white boxes would show up at his
doorstep and then they disappear.
And he wasn't sure if she was returning them or them or what was going on.
And every time he asked her,
she refused to answer what was the answer him and tell him what was going on.
So anyways,
we went through the ground floor of our office and that's where our
merchandising team is.
And then we went upstairs to our customer loyalty team,
which is our name for our call center.
And,
and he sat down next to one of our call center reps and forced her to pull up
his wife's account.
And he discovered that she had spent over $62,000 in lifetime.
So,
yeah,
hopefully we weren't instrumental in any divorce proceedings or so before
getting into the Zappos wanted to talk a little bit about what led me to Zappos.
And the story actually begins with the pizza in college.
I was running a pizza business with my roommate.
We were probably had three or 400 students in our dorm.
We were on the ground floor and we were responsible for investing in the ovens.
And we hired the workers,
set the menus,
and occasionally I was making the pizzas myself as well.
And this guy named Alfred,
who's now our CFO and COO at Zappos,
this is actually how we met,
was over pizza.
He would stop by every night in order this large pepperoni pizza for me.
And for me,
it wasn't actually that weird cause he,
I remember late nights we,
there'd be 10 of us at a Chinese restaurant somewhere and he would literally
finish everyone's leftovers.
And we had nicknames for,
I'm like human trash compactor or monster.
And so,
but then sometimes he would stop by a few hours later in order another large
pepperoni pizza for me.
And I was just thinking,
wow,
this boy can really eat well.
I found out several years later he was taking the pizzas upstairs and selling
them off by the slice.
So that's why he's our CFO and COO today.
Zappos.
So after the pizza business,
the same roommate I was running it with in the Sonjay,
he and I got together and formed a company called link exchange.
This was back in 1996 during the early.com days.
And we grew that company to about a hundred people and then ended up selling the
company to Microsoft in 1998 but what a lot of people don't know is the reason
why we ended up selling the company.
And it's because the company culture just went completely downhill.
And I remember when it was just five or 10 of us,
it was kind of like your typical.com back in the day we were working around the
clock,
sleeping under our desks,
had no idea what day of the week it was,
trying to remember to shower every few days.
And,
but it was a lot of fun.
And as we were growing,
we had friends that were on trips across the country on vacation and they would
stop by and hang out for a day or two and then we'd hire them and they never
made their way back home.
And that got us to about 15 or 20 people.
And then when we got to 20 people,
it was still a lot of fun.
But we ran out of friends.
And so we started hiring people that had all the right skill sets and
experiences,
but they weren't necessarily good for the culture.
And there wasn't any one hire that made the culture go downhill.
But just slowly over time,
by the time we got to a hundred people,
I myself dreaded getting out of the bed in the morning to go to the office.
And that was kind of a weird feeling because this was a company that I had co
founded and felt like I had lost control of the culture.
And if I felt that way,
wondered how all the other employees felt.
So that's really what drove us to sell the company to Microsoft.
And after selling the company Alpha and I got together and we formed an
investment fund and we invest in in probably about 20 or so different internet
companies and zap what's just happened to be one of them.
But over the course of a year I realized that for me investing was really
boring.
I felt like I was sitting on the sidelines and not really involved in and I
really miss being part of building something.
And so within a year I joined Zappos full time and I've been with Zappos ever
since.
I'm sure many of you have heard.
Last July Amazon announced they were acquiring Zappos in that deal officially
closed in November.
But actually it's very different from most deals that Amazon has done in most of
their deals.
The plan is to acquire the company and then integrated into Amazon for this as a
precondition condition for even talking about the scenario,
uh,
we told them we wanted to remain independent and continue to grow this apolis
brand and our culture and our way of doing business our way.
And so they've actually,
they've stayed true to their word.
So we're pretty happy with that.
And basically instead of flying once a quarter to the bay area for board
meetings,
we now fly once a quarter to Seattle.
So most people when they hear about Zappos,
think of us as an online retailer of shoes because that's how we started.
But internally we have a saying,
we say that we're a service company that just happens to sell shoes and we
actually sell a lot more than shoes now.
We sell clothing,
uh,
even beauty products,
kitchen ware house,
where in our whole goal is that we're hoping 10 years from now people won't even
realize.
We started out selling shoes online and we really just want to build our brand
to be about the very best customer service.
And we've grown from basically no sales in 1999 two in 2008 was the first time
we hit $1 billion in gross merchandise sales and we're continuing to grow,
continuing to grow in Q one of this year,
our net sales were up almost 50% year over year the previous year.
And the number one driver of all that growth has been through repeat customers
and word of mouth.
So our whole philosophy is let's take most of the money we would've spent on
paid advertising and paid marketing and instead invest in new the customer
experience and let our customers do the marketing for us.
And we've,
you know,
we're thinking 20 or 30 years from now,
we've even had customers email us and ask us if we would please run an airline
or the IRS.
And you know,
we're not going to do either of those things this year,
but you know,
20 or 30 years from now,
I wouldn't rule out a airlines that's just about the very best customer service
in customer experience.
So one brand we looked to for inspiration,
sometimes as virgin,
they're in a whole bunch of different businesses,
music,
airlines and so on.
The differences,
the virgin brand is more about being hip and cool,
whereas we just want to be about the very best customer service.
So on any given day,
about 75% of our orders are from repeat customers.
And when people ask us,
well,
what does it mean to give great customer service?
Well these are some of the questions we think about.
We think about what customers expect and then what they actually experienced.
And so when you go to our website,
I'm sure as many of you know,
we offer free shipping both ways.
So a lot of customers will order 10 different pairs of shoes,
try them on with 10 different outfits in the comfort of their living room and
some Mac,
the ones they don't like or don't want.
And we encourage that type of behavior.
We've actually found that customers with higher return rates,
uh,
maybe on a per order basis are less profitable,
but on a,
in terms of actual dollar basis end up being more profitable than customers that
never return anything at all because they ended up being more comfortable with
the process and trying out new products that they wouldn't normally try out if
it wasn't free shipping.
Both ways we think about what are the stories that they'll tell each other.
And so a lot of our investment actually,
you know,
what we found is on a lot of other ecommerce websites,
most of their investment is on what happens in order to get the customer's
credit card number.
Whereas we really focus on what happens after we get the credit credit card
number from the customer.
And uh,
there's a lot of different things we do.
We run our warehouse 24 seven which actually is not the most efficient way to
run a warehouse,
the most efficient ways to let the orders pile up.
And then the picker has higher picking density when walking around the
warehouse.
That,
but we're not trying to maximize for efficiency of the warehouse.
We're trying to maximize for the customer experience.
And our warehouse is located about 15 minutes from the ups hub in Louisville,
Kentucky.
And because of that,
and because we also do surprise upgrades to overnight shipping for most of our
loyal repeat customers,
a lot of our customers order as late as midnight eastern and then their shoe
show up on their doorstep eight hours later.
And that creates that whole wow experience and an emotional impact that causes
them to remember us for a very long time and tell their friends and family about
us.
We also have a 365 day return policy for people that I guess have trouble
committing or making up their minds.
And uh,
we also have our one h,
you know,
most websites it's very hard to find contact information.
It's usually buried five linx deep and maybe it's an address that you can email
once.
Whereas for us,
we take the exact opposite approach.
We put our one 800 number on the top of every single page of our website because
we actually want to talk to our customers.
And it's funny because sometimes I'll be speaking at advertising or branding
conferences and there's a lot of discussion about consumers being bombarded with
thousands and thousands of marketing messages every day.
How do you get your message to stand out or how to get your brand to stand out
and as kind of low tech and unsexy as it may sound,
our belief is the telephone is one of the best branding devices out there
because you have the customers undivided attention for five to 10 minutes.
And what we found is if we get the interaction right,
that's something that customers remember for a very long time.
And so we've also done studies where we found that customers that do come in
contact with us end up buying more frequently and spending more money.
So we're actually trying to figure out how do we get more customers to call us.
And it may seem weird for an internet company to really want customers to
contact us through the phone.
Most of our phone calls actually do not result in order is only about 5% of our
overall sales volume is through the telephone.
And,
but you know,
customers call for all sorts of different reasons.
Maybe it's their first time going through the returns process and they just need
a little help stepping through,
you know,
how to print out that free return label.
Or maybe they have a wedding this weekend and they just want some fashion
advice.
And,
uh,
we have some customers that call us,
I think just because they're lonely and we'll talk to them as well.
Uh,
we run our call center very differently from most call centers.
Most call centers are again focusing on efficiency,
viewing that as in the lens of expense minimisation whereas for us,
we really view it through a branding lens.
What can we do to really build the Zappos brand should be about the very best
customer service.
And what we found is that on average,
every customer does call us at least once,
sometime during their lifetime.
And if we'd get that interaction right,
it's something they remember for a very long time and tell their friends and
about.
And that's really what drives a lot of our growth.
So we don't have scripts.
Uh,
we don't measure call times.
Most call centers are all about how many customers can each rep talk to,
which translates into how quickly can you get the customer off the phone.
In fact,
our,
um,
I just found out,
got an email yesterday,
our longest phone call was seven and a half hours long from last week I think.
And I'm not sure how the bathroom situation worked out for that,
but,
but we,
in fact if someone calls and is looking for a specific pair of shoes,
if we're out of stock of their size,
everyone's trained to look on at least three competitor websites.
If they find it,
they're direct the customer to the competitor and obviously we lose that sale.
But we're not trying to maximize for every single transaction.
We were trying to build a lifelong relationship with our customers.
So for all this about building our brand to be about customer service,
customer service is actually not our number one priority.
Our number one priority is company culture.
And our whole belief is that if we get the culture right,
that most of the other stuff like delivering great customer service or building
a long term enduring brand or business will just happen naturally on its own.
So there's a lot of stuff that we really invest in on the culture side and it
starts with the hiring process.
When we hire people,
we actually do two completely different sets of interviews.
The first set is kind of your standard stuff that the hiring manager and his or
her team we'll do interview for fit within the team,
relevant experience,
technical ability and so on.
But then we do a second set of interviews done by our HR department purely for
culture fit and they have to pass both in order to be hired.
So we've actually passed on a lot of really smart,
talented people that we know can make an immediate impact on our top or bottom
line.
But if they're not a culture fit,
then we won't hire them.
And the reverse is true too.
Even if someone is a superstar at their specific job function,
if they're bad for our culture,
we'll fire them just for that reason.
And our performance reviews are 50% based on whether the employee is living in
inspiring the core values of the company,
which is essentially a formalized definition of our culture.
The other thing that we do is everyone that's hired into our headquarters in Las
Vegas,
it doesn't matter what position,
uh,
goes through five weeks of training.
One Week is in Kentucky later on,
uh,
where our warehouses,
they do all the warehouse functions,
picking,
packing,
shipping,
receiving and so on.
But the first four weeks they go through the exact same training,
the same training as our call center rep,
and we go over company history,
the importance of company culture,
our philosophy about customer service.
And then you're actually on the phone for two weeks taking calls from customers.
And the reason we have everyone,
regardless of what department they're eventually going to end up and do that is
because if we're serious about building our brand to be about the very best
customer service,
then customer service shouldn't just be a department.
It should be the entire company.
And during that process we,
we,
it's an additional vetting period for us because it's pretty hard to fake and
attitude for that long a period of time.
And there's actually been people that have,
we've had to let go during that process because they felt customer service was
beneath them.
And uh,
this is all before they actually started their actual job.
The other thing we do is at the end of the first week of training,
we make an offer to the entire class and the offers this,
we will pay you for the time you've already spent training plus a bonus of
$2,000 to quit and leave the company right now.
And that's a standing offer until the end of the training.
And then we actually extended a couple of months after that and up to $3,000.
And the reason we do that is because we want,
you know,
in Las Vegas there's plenty of other call centers.
Starting pay is $11 an hour and we don't want someone that's there just for a
paycheck.
We want employees that are there because they really believe in the longterm
vision of the company and really feel like this company culture is one that they
want to be a part of and contribute to.
And only about two or 3% of people end up taking the offer.
When we first started this offer a few years ago,
it actually started out at $100 and we keep upping the offers now at two or
$3,000 because we feel like not enough people are taking the offer.
Uh,
but our original intention was actually to weed out the people that would have
probably left the company who had been fired six or nine months down the road.
But what we found is the biggest benefit to it is actually from the people that
don't take the offer because they still have to go home over the weekend,
talk to their friends and family and ask themselves,
is this a company that I really believe in and want to commit to?
And when they decided to turn down that easy,
two or $3,000 when they come back to the office on Monday through that much more
engaged and passionate and committed.
And by far that's been the biggest benefit of a of doing that.
The other thing we have is something called a culture book,
which a,
I'll give instructions later on for how to get one for free.
But it's something we put out once a year and we've done it for I think six
years now.
And we ask all our employees to write a few paragraphs about what the Zappos
culture means to them.
And except for Typos it's unedited.
So it's like when you go to Amazon customer reviews of a product,
these are essentially employee reviews of the company and it's also,
it's organized by departments.
So you can see how the warehouse culture might be slightly different from the
accounting culture.
And I'll make that freely available.
We also train everyone on how to use Twitter.
If you go to twitter.zappos.com there's a link where you can see the 500 or so
Zappos employees that are active on Twitter.
And there's another page where you can see in a aggregated a page of all all the
employees tweets together.
So that can also give you a pretty good sense of our culture.
So for the next several years,
at least the way we're thinking of the Zappos brand is internally we referred to
it as the three C's,
clothing,
customer service and culture.
And this is essentially based on the lifecycle of the customer.
So customers that have never heard of Zappos have no idea what we do.
Uh,
we want them to know that we have a great selection of clothing and footwear and
other product categories.
Once they know about that,
then we want them to know that we're all about the very best customer service.
And that's not something that so much we tell them as they experience when they
call our call center or experience that surprise upgrade to overnight shipping
or see how easy the free return shipping is.
And once they know that we're all about the very best customer service,
then we want them to know about our culture and our core values because that's
really the platform that makes everything possible.
So we've actually had customers tell us that when they get that perfect pair of
shoes or perfect outfit that's apples is happiness in a box.
So whether it's the happiness that employees that that customers feel when they
get that perfect outfit or the happiness that customers feel when they
experience great service or have a great customer experience or the happiness
that employees feel from being part of a culture where the core values of the
company match their own personal values.
The thing that really ties all of these things together that we realize is that
Zappos is really just about delivering happiness,
whether it's customers or employees.
And we apply that same philosophy to vendors as well.
And so hence the title of my book that just came out.
So wanted to talk about to a books.
When you come on the tour,
you'll,
first thing you see in our lobby is the Zappos library.
And we have about 30 or 40 titles there.
And it's a not a lending library,
it's actually giving library.
The books are freely available to employees and to visitors alike.
But two of the titles that we really,
uh,
really that I,
and also I personally really like are good to great by Jim Collins and tribal
leadership.
And in fact we had partnered with the authors of tribal leadership to the Audio
version is actually available for free to download from the Zappos website.
And in fact we even teach classes on both of these books at Zappos.
And the reason why I find both of these books interesting is because the authors
did their research and looked at what separated the great companies in terms of
longterm financial performance from just the good ones.
And they found that there were two important ingredients that the great
companies had,
that the good ones are me too.
Mediocre ones generally didn't have and and they were actually surprised by what
the,
what they found through the research.
And the first ingredient that they found the great companies had was uh,
they all had very strong cultures.
And so we formalize the definition of art culture into 10 core values and the
differences the,
a lot of,
especially larger corporations have,
they might call them core values or guiding principles or uh,
or so on.
The problem is usually they're very lofty sounding.
They kind of read like a press release that the marketing department put out and
maybe you learn about it on day one of orientation and then it becomes this
meaningless pack on the lobby wall.
For us,
we actually wanted to come up with committable core values and by committable we
mean we're willing to hire or fire people based on them independent of their
actual job performance.
And when you use that criteria,
it's actually a pretty hard list to come up with.
And we actually spent a year coming up with it.
It wasn't just a few high level executives spend a weekend at an offsite and
came up with the list.
Uh,
instead,
this was about five years ago,
I emailed the entire company and just ask them,
what should our core values be?
Got a whole bunch of different responses back.
And then we went back and forth for a year and then finally came up with our
list of 10 core values.
So this is our list of 10.
Uh,
you can actually,
if you do a Google search for Zappos core values,
it should be the first thing that pops up.
The other actually interesting litmus test for when we were trying to come up
with our core values and in general,
uh,
to,
to think about for any company that's thinking of core values is if you do a
Google search for any one of these individual core values on almost all of them,
Zappos is the number one result or,
or on the first page.
And for almost any other companies,
uh,
if you searched for their core values,
they're nowhere to be found if you search for them one at a time.
So we actually have interview questions for each and every one of these.
Probably the one that trips us up the most in the hiring process is the last
one.
Be Humble cause there's a lot of really smart,
talented people out there that are also egotistical.
And for us it's just not a question,
we just won't hire them.
But it's one of those things that is actually probably the hardest to have an
interview question for cause we can't say how humble are you and they say I'm
the most humble person in the world.
But one way we actually test for this is uh,
you know I talked about how we'll pick you up from the airport and Zappos
shuttle and give you two or wolf welfare candidates.
A lot of them are from out of town,
do the same thing,
pick,
pick them up and his apple shuttle,
give them a tour and then afterwards they'll spend the day interviewing.
At the end of the day of interviews,
the recruiter will actually go back to the shuttle driver and ask how he or she
was treated.
And if they weren't treated well,
it's not even question.
It doesn't matter how well the day of interviews went.
We won't hire that person.
Uh,
and so number three,
I'll give some examples,
create fun and a little weirdness.
One of our interview questions is on a scale of one to 10,
how weird are you?
And,
uh,
you know,
if you're one,
you might be a little bit too straight laced for the Zappos culture,
10 maybe a little bit to psychotic for us.
Um,
but really it's not so much the number that we care about.
It's a how they answer because our belief is that everyone is a little weird
somehow.
And this is really more just a fun way saying that we really recognize and
celebrate each person's individuality and we want their true personalities to
come out and shine in the workplace.
You know,
there's so many people where there are different person at home on weekends
versus when they're inside the office and people in Corporate America leave a
little bit of themselves or in a lot of cases,
big part of themselves at home.
And we really strive to create an environment where people are just comfortable
being themselves.
So instead of worrying about work life separation,
it's about work life integration where it's just the same person.
And uh,
you know,
not only are you comfortable being yourself,
but when you connect with your coworkers,
it's not just coworker relationships,
but a true friendships that end up forming where you would choose to hang out
with these people even if you weren't working at the same company together.
And so for example,
for managers,
we actually encourage them to spend 10 to 20% of their time outside the office,
uh,
with their team and whoever they work with.
And initially,
uh,
the reaction we get back,
especially from people from other companies as well is that sounds fun,
but is it really working?
Uh,
I had endless list of things to do,
but then we go back and survey the managers that have done it and we asked them
how much more productive and efficient is your team because,
uh,
communication is better.
There's higher levels of trust.
People are willing to do favors for each other cause they're doing favors for
friends,
not just coworkers.
And the answers we get back in terms of increased productivity range anywhere
from 20% to 100% more productive.
So kind of worst case scenario,
you're breaking even and having more fun with it.
Um,
number four,
be adventurous,
creative and open minded.
One of our questions for the interview is on a scale of one to 10,
how lucky are you in life?
One is,
I don't know why bad things always seem to happen to me,
and 10 is I don't know why good things always seem to happen to me.
Well,
we don't want to hire the ones because they're bad luck and they'll bring bad
luck to Zappos.
That's not good for us.
Um,
but this was actually inspired by a research study I'd read about a few years
ago where they actually asked that exact same question to random group of
people,
got answers all over the board.
And then afterwards they had the subjects do a task and the task was to go
through a newspaper and count the number of photos that were in that newspaper.
And when they were done,
give the answer to the researcher.
But what the participants didn't know was that it was actually a fake newspaper
and sprinkled throughout the newspaper where these headlines that would say
things like if you're reading this headline,
you can stop.
The answer's 37 plus collect an extra hundred dollars.
And what they found was that the people that consider themselves unlucky in life
generally didn't notice the headlines.
You know,
they went through the task at hand and eventually came up with the right answer.
And the people that consider themselves lucky in life generally stopped early
and made an extra hundred dollars.
So the takeaway is that it's not so much that people are inherently lucky or
unlucky,
but luck is really more about being open to opportunity beyond just how the task
or situation presents itself.
And so that's why we asked that question for a core value.
Number four,
one of our other core values is about being open.
And honest and we really embrace transparency,
whether it's with our customers,
with our employees or with our vendors.
So for example,
with our customers,
we last quarter we have a quarterly all hands meeting and last quarter we
actually live stream that on the Internet for,
to the public for employees we have this monthly newsletter called ask anything
where it's literally that they can ask,
employees,
can ask about financials or what brands we're going to carry or really any
question we want and we'll get the right person to answer that question and then
compile it all with the questions anonymously and then send it out as a
newsletter to our employees once a month.
And with our vendors we have an extra net,
we work with about 1500 different brands and they can all log into our extranet,
our backend system in viewed the exact same information our own buyers and
merchandisers can see so they can see on hand inventory,
uh,
what sales,
our profitability,
markdowns and so on.
And when we first opened this up to them,
their response was,
great,
I love all this extra information,
but aren't you worried the information is going to get into the hands of
competitors.
And I'm sure realistically at some,
some of the information probably does make its way into the hands of competitors
at some point.
But on the flip side,
we now have an extra 1500 pairs of eyes helping us co manage our business and
they're not on our payroll.
And a lot of times they'll catch stuff that our own buyers and merchandisers
might miss because our buyers and merchandisers have portfolios of anywhere from
20 to 30 brands.
So they may miss that one style that's taking off.
And our,
um,
in our brand partners,
I really just focused on this and logging and several times a day reading the
nightlys,
you know,
re reports and it really just makes them a true partner in the business.
So this is a common reaction.
We get happy for you.
Zappos,
you have this great culture,
but,
uh,
you know,
the stuff you do would never work at my company.
And what's interesting is that the,
from the research that was done in good to great,
what they found was that it actually doesn't matter what your core values are.
So I'm not up here trying to say other companies should adopt the Zappos culture
and core values because in most cases that would probably not be the right
choice,
the right decision for another company.
But what I am saying is that having core values that you actually commit to Ma
is what matters is not what the core values are themselves.
And what they found was the most important thing in their research was that you
had a strong culture,
that you had alignment throughout the organization.
That's where the real power comes from.
And when we rolled out our core values,
it was actually one of those things that even myself kind of resisted initially,
initially cause it felt like one of those big corporate things to do.
But what we found was when we really committed to them and truly committed,
meaning willing to hire and fire people based on them willing to do performance
reviews based on them what within a relatively short period of time,
we've,
the entire organization really changed when it became integrated in our language
and our default way of thinking.
And it empowers every single employee to really make decisions for themselves.
They just need to ask what's our longterm vision and is this more in line with
our core values or less aligned with our core values.
And it also enables employees to call each other out front,
whether even if they're in different departments or if it's a front line
employee calling out a VP.
So we found that it's been hugely,
hugely powerful and really is what enables us to scale our culture.
And the part of it is the only way as culture can scale.
You know,
most companies as they get bigger than company culture goes downhill over time.
Uh,
not only do we not want that to happen,
but we actually wanted to get stronger and stronger.
And the only way that can happen is if every employee views as part of his or
her job description,
uh,
living in inspiring the culture in others.
And so one analogy I like to think of sometimes is like when you watch the
discovery channel and over the Serengeti or whatever,
there's 50,000 of flock of 50,000 birds flying.
And if you take a step back,
it looks like this one giant organism that's flying in unison.
And the reality is there is no head bird that is leading the group.
But what there are,
are varies.
Every bird has pretty much the same DNA and they have very simple instructions
encoded in their DNA,
like stayed this many,
this many number of inches away from the bird on the right,
this many from the left and so on.
And when they all follow those same rules,
they're able to flock together.
And so analogously at the core values are like the DNA that enables the versus
function as a unit that whether it's,
you know,
10 birds or 50,000 birds.
And that's really how we're thinking of how we're going to scale the company
culture at Zappos.
Um,
I'm not,
I'm going to make this presentation available,
but uh,
you know,
sometimes the reaction that we get from other other companies is,
okay,
you're an internet company.
I use special rules apply to you.
And the reason why I included those other stories in there are because one of
them for example,
is the Atlanta refrigeration company in Atlanta,
Georgia.
They do refrigeration repairs out in the field.
And so in some ways you can't think of a more opposite company or industry.
Then Zappos and they came through our offices and then actually went through our
Zappos insights program where we help them figure out their core values and how
to build their own strong cultures.
And then they went back and within a relatively short period of time,
uh,
their customers are happier,
their employees are happier.
It's really neat,
actually seen the before and after pictures and their profits and revenues are
up.
So it's just pretty cool seeing the same concepts apply and work in other
industries.
So going back to the good to great and tribal leadership talked about how there
were,
uh,
two important ingredients that separated the great companies from just the good
ones.
First one was culture.
And then the second one was that,
and this again,
I think surprised the researchers,
was that the great companies had a vision that had a higher purpose beyond just
money or profits or being number one in a market.
And kind of the irony there is that by not making profits the number one
priority of the company,
uh,
or the higher purpose of the company,
it actually enabled these companies to generate more profits in the longterm.
So sometimes when I speak at entrepreneur conferences,
I get asked what's a good market to go into where they can make a lot of money?
And my response to them is,
instead of thinking about where you can make a lot of money,
think about what are you so passionate about doing that?
You'd be happy doing it for 10 years.
And even if you never made a dime,
and that's what you should be doing.
And kind of the ironic thing is the money will actually follow.
So,
you know,
we've all heard of craigslist.
Uh,
he didn't set out to make money.
He was passionate about the community and now it's one of the top trafficked
websites on the internet.
So I like to say chase the vision,
not the money.
There was a movie that came out a,
uh,
I think a couple of years ago I called notorious.
Uh,
I think it only lasted a week in the movie theater,
but,
um,
but I saw it and a in it biggie smalls,
also known as notorious Vig,
uh,
is well,
puff daddy says to biggie smalls,
don't chase the paper,
chase the dream.
I just want an excuse to put this picture up
anyways.
So if you're an entrepreneur,
say,
think about what would you be so passionate about doing that?
You'd be happy doing it for 10 years,
even if you've never made a dime from it.
And if you have employees met,
what's the larger vision and greater purpose in their work beyond just money or
profits or being number one in a market.
And there's a lot of,
um,
you know,
consultants in books that talk about how to motivate employees and they work to
a certain extent.
And there's different ways you can motivate employees.
You can motivate them through incentives.
A lot of companies do that.
You can mode motivate them through recognition.
A lot of corporate American motivates through fear.
Uh,
but our belief is that there's a huge difference between motivation and
inspiration.
And if you can inspire your employees through a vision that has a greater
purpose beyond just money or profits or being number one in a market,
and if you can inspire employees by having and committing to corporate core
values that match their own personal values,
then you can accomplish so much more and you don't really need to worry about
the motivation part of it.
So,
uh,
this is a look at how the Zappos brand has evolved over the years.
In 1999 are we,
our vision was let's just have the largest selection of shoes online.
And,
and then about four years into it,
we sat around and asked ourselves,
what do we want to be when we grow up?
Do we want to be about shoes or do we want to be about something more
meaningful?
And that's when we decided we wanted our brand to be about the very best
customer service.
And when we did that like something,
it's kind of surprised us what happens suddenly once we communicated it out to
our employees,
we found that employees were suddenly a lot more engaged and passionate about
the company and when customers called and they could sense that the person on
the end of the phone wasn't there just for a paycheck,
but truly wanted to provide great service.
And when vendors came and visited our offices,
we've found that they wanted to stay longer or come more frequently because uh,
that enthusiasm we're off onto them,
rubbed off onto them.
And then in 2005 was when we rolled out our core values and decided not only do
we want culture to be important,
but we in fact want it to be the number one priority of the company.
Because if we get that right,
then the customer service will come naturally as a byproduct of that.
And in 2007,
we started asking ourselves,
okay,
what do we mean by great customer service?
There's lots of different ways to do,
uh,
give great service.
Amazon is a customer centric company as well,
but they have a different approach.
They're more about high tech and,
and removing friction.
And whereas we really want to do the more,
uh,
human,
have the more human connection so we're more high touch instead of high tech and
really develop that personal emotional connection with them.
And then 2009 was when we took a step back and realize really the thing that
ties all of this together is just about delivering happiness,
whether it's the customers or employees or vendors as well.
So,
um,
one is just tell another pizza story.
And this actually happened a couple of years ago in Santa Monica,
California.
And,
uh,
I was speaking at a sketchers sales conference and it was a long day.
And then at the end of the day we decided to go bar hopping in the Santa Monica
area.
And Cause I,
I never done that before.
And I,
I've gone bar hopping but not bar hopping in the Santa Monica area before.
And so I think there were three of us from Zappos,
three people from Skechers.
One of the brands that we work with went to the first bar order to rent.
Someone ordered a round of drinks.
And then,
because it had been a long day,
someone ordered a round of shots.
And so we took the shots and drink the drinks and then went to the second bar
and someone else ordered a round of drinks to pay back for the first round of
drinks.
And then someone else ordered around a shots to pay back for that first amount
of shots and you can't waste alcohol.
So we took the shots and we finished the drinks and then we went to the third
bar and then actually don't remember how many drinks or shots we had after that.
But what I do know is that your last call is 2:00 AM in California.
And,
uh,
lights went on and then we started heading back to the hotel room.
And,
um,
and one of the girls from Skechers was talking about this pepperoni pizza that
she was craving and asked if we wanted to go on and on it.
And we said,
yeah,
that sounds great.
You know,
we'd been drinking pretty hungry.
And uh,
she's like,
oh,
I cannot wait to like go order the room service.
Like I checked it out on the room service menu before we left.
It was on page 17.
It was the second item down.
And uh,
when it comes,
I know it's going to be hot,
so I'm not going to let it burn the roof of my mouth.
I'm going to like smell it first.
And we look,
the odors go in and it was only a five minute walk,
but it seemed much longer than that because she would not stop talking about the
pepperoni pizza.
So anyways,
we finally wind up in the hotel room and she's all excited.
She calls room service and then 10 seconds later she hangs up the phone all
dejected.
And I asked her what's wrong?
And apparently at that hotel,
they don't serve hot food after 11:00 PM.
And so she was really dejected and sad.
And so to try to cheer up,
I say,
well,
did you know in college I used to make pepperoni pizzas?
And she looked at me and he was like,
that's so not helpful right now.
And then the three of us from Zappos and you're like,
oh.
And we were more than a little bit inebriated,
say called Zappos called Zappos will take care of you.
We're all about the best customer service
and in our minds that really was the funniest thing ever.
And uh,
and so she actually took us up on our dare and put the phone on speaker phone
called Zappos and,
uh,
you know,
the rest of us are in the background trying not to make a new noise,
but you know,
trying to laugh as quietly as possible.
And,
uh,
in the rep said,
thanks for calling Zappos,
how can I help you?
And sketchers girl says,
oh,
thank goodness you answered.
I'm in Santa Monica right now and been eyeing this thing on the room service
menu.
Page 17,
item number two,
pepperoni pizza.
But they don't serve hot food after 11:00 PM kind of hotel does not serve hot
food after 11:00 PM is there anything you can do for me?
First there was an awkward silence
and then the reps it,
you know,
he called Zappos,
right?
We sell shoes,
we sell clothes,
we don't sell pizza yet
in the sketchers girl said,
yeah,
but I heard you're all about the very best customer service and the rest of it.
Okay,
hold on
and put us on hold for two minutes and then came back and listed the five
closest places in the Santa Monica area that we're still open and delivering
pizza at that hour.
Now I hesitate a little shells the story,
cause I don't want all of you to start calling Zapples ordering pizza.
But you know,
obviously we don't have a process of procedure for late night drunk pizza
orders.
But,
but I just,
I think it's just a fun story because if you get the culture right and make sure
everyone understands the longterm vision of the company,
you don't need a process and procedure for everything.
And these types of situations,
these stories are just created automatically,
uh,
literally for us thousands and thousands of times every single day.
And that's how we've really built our brand.
So,
um,
uh,
well,
which it was 3:00 AM by that time.
So we,
we,
uh,
we did not actually end up ordering the pizza,
but,
um,
but she actually went back and put together this care package for the rep and
the rep is very happy now and,
but now she's a customer for life and has probably,
she's told that story I'm sure many,
many times.
And,
and,
and that's really what,
you know,
these are the types of things that we think about.
Like where the store,
where does the story begin and where does it end?
And for us,
the story doesn't end when we get the credit card.
It's really just this ongoing lifelong relationship with,
uh,
with customers.
And we're really think of ourselves as being in the stories and memories,
business experience or experiencing emotions business.
And so that's what eventually led us to really think about building the brand to
be about happiness or delivering happiness.
So,
um,
wanted to,
uh,
take a step back from all this business talking,
actually have you guys think about this question,
what is your goal in life?
And,
and so whatever your actual,
uh,
you know,
answers,
think about that.
And what's interesting is that if you actually asked different people this
question,
you'll get all sorts of different answers.
Some people will say to grow a company when people would say,
get a great job or get a boyfriend,
girlfriend,
and then ask yourself why.
So whatever you had as your goal in life,
ask yourself why.
And then people will come up with different,
uh,
answers,
retire early,
make money,
find a soulmate,
uh,
and then ask yourself why again,
and you know,
people will come up with the next set of answers,
but if you keep asking yourself why over and over again,
what's interesting is that eventually everyone ends up with the same answer.
And that's whatever their goal in life is.
Whatever they're pursuing they believe will make them happier.
So a couple of years ago,
having nothing to do with Zappos,
I started reading books and articles and so on,
uh,
about,
this field of research that's essentially about the signs of happiness.
The formal name for it is positive psychology and it actually didn't exist prior
to 1998.
So I'm not talking about,
you know,
go do the self help section of a bookstore and read books that say,
think positive and you'll be happy.
Uh,
I'm talking about actual research that's been done in prior to 1998 almost all
of psychology was about looking at people that had something wrong with them and
then figuring out how to make them more normal,
but almost nobody bothered to study.
How do you look at normal people and make them happier?
So just more as a hobby and everything.
I thought,
oh,
that's pretty interesting.
And so I started reading books and articles on the topic and one of the
consistent things that has come out of the research is that people are very bad
at predicting what will make them happy in the long term.
Most people think once I get x,
then I'll be happier.
Once I choose x,
then I'll be happy when the research shows that's not true.
There are studies of lottery winners.
For example,
you look at their happiness level right before winning the lottery and then look
at their happiness level a year later and a year later it's the same or maybe
even a little bit lower than it was right before they won the lottery.
And the reverse is true as well.
There's people that have become unexpectedly blind and you look at their
happiness level a year later in a year later,
it's actually a right back to where it was before they became blind.
So I thought this was interesting and then started thinking about it and uh,
both for my own personal life but also for businesses as well.
Because if people are bad at predicting what will make them happy,
then us.
For us,
trying to build a brand around customer service isn't just as simple as asking
customers what do they want?
Because they may not know.
And same thing for employees.
If we're trying to build a culture with a lot of happy employees,
you can't always just ask employees what it is that will make them happy because
they,
what the research has shown is that people are bad at predicting what will
actually make them happen.
And you know,
for our business and yours as well,
there's a lot of science behind a lot of stuff we do.
We look at conversion,
a customer acquisition metrics,
repeat customer behavior and so on.
And I don't know what the right percentage is,
but if the ultimate goal is happiness,
then you know,
what percent of your time do you want to spend studying and learning about the
science of happiness,
how much happier could you be and how much could that potentially help your
business,
whether it's in dealing with employees or customers or vendors.
You know,
a lot of people go through decades trying to get to this ultimate destination of
happiness.
And then when they get there,
realize it's either very short lived or maybe not even there at all.
What if by studying the signs of happiness,
you know,
and the research that's already been done,
just reading up on it a little bit,
you can kind of maybe skip some of the steps and just go straight to the
happiness part of it.
So I thought that was interesting.
So I just wanted to share a few different frameworks to kind of cliff notes
version of what I thought was interesting from the stuff that I've read about.
And the first a frameworks is that happiness is really just about four things.
Perceived control,
perceived progress,
connectedness,
meaning the number in depth of your relationships and vision are meaning being
part of something bigger than yourself.
And what's interesting is that you can not only apply this to you your own life,
but you can apply it to a business as well.
So for example,
for perceived progress in our merchandising,
each department we used to hire employees entry level.
And then give them all the training and mentorship and so on.
They get certified and then they'd get a promotion 18 months later and then they
get another,
uh,
you know,
set of training and certification.
And then 18 months after that they'd get a promotion to become a buyer,
which within Zappos is a pretty big deal.
So it took him three years to become a buyer.
Well,
instead of giving a promotion every 18 months,
we changed it a few years ago so that we gave smaller promotions every six
months.
And even though nothing had changed,
they still had to go through the same certification and mentorship and training
and so on.
Except we found that,
and it still took them exactly three years to become a buyer.
But we found that because there was this ongoing sense of perceived progress,
that employees were much happier and it costs the company nothing to do that.
Another,
uh,
framework is Maslow's hierarchy.
There's a great book called peak by Chip Conley Pak,
where he actually condenses this into three levels and applies it to employees
and customers and investors as well.
And so for example,
for employees,
the three levels of the pyramid are in terms of what they think of their work,
whether they think of it as a job versus career versus calling.
And our whole goal at Zappos is to move them up.
The pyramid to think of their time at Zappos has a calling and we'd still want
employees at Zappos 10 years from now.
And the only way that's going to happen is if we provide all the training and
mentorship and so on,
so that they feel like they're growing both personally and professionally.
And so we offer a lot of different classes.
Uh,
we have 30 or 40 different courses now and they're not just professional
courses.
There's also,
for example,
one on this,
the science of happiness that,
uh,
that helps them with their personal growth as well.
And,
uh,
the last framework I want to share,
it was three different types of happiness,
pleasure,
engagement and meaning.
The first type I like to call the Rockstar type of happiness cause it's about
always chasing the next high.
And it's great if you can sustain it.
Uh,
the problem is it's very hard to sustain unless you're basically a rock star and
it's what the research has shown is out of these three types of happiness,
as of as soon as your sources stimming light goes down,
it goes away.
Your happiness level just drops right back down to where it was before.
The second type is called flow.
There's a book by the same name and it's about those moments and we've all
experienced this.
For some people it might be while running for other people it might be painting,
but it's about when you're so into something that you're doing that three hours
passed by.
But it seems like only 20 minutes have passed by.
And a con and other attributes that,
uh,
that are associated with this are that you lose a sense of self consciousness or
even self because you're so into what you're doing.
And professional athletes referred to it as being in the zone where peak
performance meets peak engagement.
And kind of the strategy there is just notice when that happens and then either
change who you hang out with,
your,
your friends or your environment or your job or where you live to try to have
that type of occurrence happened more frequently.
And with the research has shown is that this is actually the second longest
lasting type of happiness.
And the third type,
it's about being part of something bigger than yourself.
And so that might mean for some people volunteering for their favorite charity
for example.
And what the research has shown is this is actually the longest lasting type of
happiness.
So what I thought was interesting is most people go through life chasing after
the first type thinking.
Once I could sustain it on an ongoing basis,
which is pretty much impossible,
then I'll uh,
worry about the second type.
And then if I ever get around to it,
then I'll worry about the third type when based purely on the data from the
research,
the proper strategy should be focused on the third type of happiness first.
And then layer on,
on top of that,
the second type.
And then the first one's really just icing on the cake.
So a some books that I recommend,
uh,
probably the one that's made the biggest impact on my life over the past five
years is happiness hypothesis.
Uh,
the author looks at a whole bunch of different religions,
philosophers and uh,
Eh,
and,
and religions philosophies and cultures from different time periods.
And each of them has a different belief as to what happiness means or how to
achieve it.
Uh,
but then what I found was interesting is he compares their beliefs to actual
scientific research that's been done and then either agrees or disagrees with
different parts of their beliefs.
Um,
you can email me,
tony@deliveringhappinessbooks.com,
uh,
or tony@zappos.com will work as well,
for a copy of this presentation.
Uh,
also the culture book I talked about,
happy to send out for free.
It's actually on backorder I think a couple of weeks right now,
but as soon as it gets in,
we'll send it out to you next time you're in Las Vegas.
Uh,
if you come for a tour Monday through Thursdays,
tours.zappos.com and,
uh,
just wanted to end with,
you know,
the research has shown that great businesses are the ones that are able to
combine profits,
passion and purpose.
Uh,
and what I thought was really interesting,
and this was kind of a weird Aha moment for me when I took a step back,
was that the research from the science of happiness,
it's about being able to combine pleasure or passion and purpose.
So in a weird way,
it's almost like what makes for great businesses on this,
like a fractal of,
uh,
what makes sense for individual happiness.
And this is really what we're trying to achieve at Zappos and what we're hoping.
What I'm hoping that the book will that just came out,
will,
uh,
help other businesses,
is really think about happiness as a business model and just want to leave you
guys with thinking about what percent of your time do you want to spend learning
about the science of happiness and how can learning about it really help
yourself personally,
your business or your brand.
And if the research shows that businesses that have a higher purpose actually
are able to achieve more longterm profits,
uh,
and if the research shows that,
you know,
for you personally,
if you have a higher purpose that actually leads to more happiness,
then I don't think about what is Your Business,
your company is higher purpose in what is your own higher purpose.
You know,
and I'm not up here trying to sell more shoes,
uh,
but if you go through this presentation,
you've been inspired to focus more on making customers happier by really
thinking more about the customer experience or customer service,
or you've been inspired to really make employees happier by focusing more on
company culture,
or you've just been inspired to make yourself happier by learning a little bit
more about the science of happiness.
If any of those things have happened,
then I'll have done my part in helping Zappos achieve our higher purpose,
which is all about delivering happiness to the world.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible].